[موسيقى]
يخيل الينا ونحن نرى هذه المناظر من
السماء اننا باقصى الغرب الامريكي
ابعدما نكون من ذلك اننا بالجنوب الفرنسي
ضمن السلسله الجبليه المعروفه
او ما يطلق عليها اسم كولورادو البروفونس
حيث نقترب من هذه المنحوتات الغريبه
والمسارات الوعره والوديان العميقه كل سنه
ياتي حوالي 300 الف سائح لخوض مغامرات من
نوع خاص هذا رائعا جدا هذا تباين في
المناظر الطبيعيه امر لا يصدق لم نكن
نتوقع رؤيه كل هذا
انه الفن الفن الخالص حقيقه انها مناظر
مبهره للاعين
انها رائعه شبيهه بكوكب المريخ لكن في
فرنسا بمثابه مغامره صغيره ضمن الفضاء
[موسيقى]
بالجنوب الفرنسي كما في اسبانيا
الكولورادو تعني الطبيعه الملونه هنا
التلال مزينه باللون الاحمر والابيض
والذهبي انها ظاهره طبيعيه منذ زمن بعيد
يفسرها كذلك وجود بحر في المنطقه
هذه الالوان الناتجه عن تغير طبيعي
جيولوجي عمره اكثر من 200 مليون سنه مع
اكسده الحديد الموجود في الطين والذي
احدثته مياه البحر في ذلك الوقت
المغره او هذا المسحوق الطيني استخدمه
الانسان منذ عصور ما قبل التاريخ في اعمال
الطلاء والصباغه فالوانه لا تتغير ولا
تتلاشى
عندما نفتت الرمله نرى المواد الصبغيه
المكونه للمغره
وهنا يبدو لنا اللون الاحمر وهنا مثلا
يبدو اللون الاصفر
قليلا باصابعنا فيظل اللون الاصفر عالقا
بها هذه الاصباغ تم استخدامها منذ القدم
ونجدها خاصه في رسومات ولوحات عصر النهضه
لكن اذا كانت الالوان طبيعيه فان يد
الانسان هي التي حفرت في هذه الصخور لتشكل
لنا وتستخدم ماده المغره في مجال
الصناعه ابتداء من القرن التاسع عشر بدا
العمال بفصل المغره والرمل عن طريق التدفق
الاصطناعي للمياه ما ادى الى صقل هذه
الصخور الهشه برفق وبفضل سواعد الرجال
تم تشكيل الطوب بعنايه وصار كولورادو
البروفونس انذاك احد اهم مواقع تصدير
المغره في العالم الى درجه اصبح فيها
الحفر اعمق بكثير لاجل استخراج هذه الماده
الصبغيه
تحت ارض مدينه غيستخل توجد العشرات من
المناجم مثل هذا والتي استخرج منها ما يصل
الى 50 الف طن من المغره سنويا بالنسبه
للجيولوجي دافيد فان هذه التجاويف
العملاقه تشهد على العمل الجبار الذي قام
به العمال في ذلك الوقت
انه منجم يعود تاريخه الى اواخر القرن
التاسع عشر واوائل القرن العشرين بعض
الالات الا زالت في مكانها مثل الرافع
التي وضعت هنا عام 23 انه استغلال طبيعي
في ذروه تلك المغامره الصناعيه وسط
على السطح لا تزال هناك العديد من بقايا
ذلك الزمن
مثل معمل المغره القديم هذا الذي يرغب
دافيد في تحويله الى متحف
اننا اذا في معمل بوني
يبدو الزمن متوقفا في هذا المكان
ندخل هنا الى قاعه المرسم لنجد فيها هذه
اللافتات التي تحتوي على الاحرف الاولى
لاسماء الالوان وصفاتها كالاصفر والداكن
جدا وغيرها من ميزات ماده المغرى التي تم
انتاجها هنا وتم استخدامها في صناعه
المطاط وصدرت الى كل منه ولندن
[موسيقى]
هذه المغامره الصناعيه ان صح القول عرفتها
كلار حين كانت صغيره جدا اشتغلت في هذا
المحجر الخاص بوالدها تراث انتقل اليها
بعد ذلك
عندما اتيت اليها كنت ابلغ سبع سنوات فقط
واخوات تكبرنني بسنتين هذه الحرفه رائعه
رائعه جدا قصر المغره هو ما كنت اقوم به
مع ابي لكنها كانت حرفه شاقه
مع مجيء الاصباغ الاصطناعيه فقدت صناعه
المغره واهجها بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه
لكن الماده الملونه منحت المنطقه باكملها
شيئا من بريقها المشع كيف لا وقريه غوسيون
تعد من اجمل الاماكن في فرنسا الفضل في
ذلك يعود الى اللون المغره الذي يزين جميع
واجهات المنازل وكنوع من رد الجميل لهذه
الماده انشئ من اجلها مركز يعرف بميزاتها
وفوائدها
انها الماده التي مشيتم عليها طوال اليوم
مزجتها للتو مع اللون الابيض
ضمن هذه الورشه التعليميه يكتشف الصغار
خبرات الاسلاف
امسكها بلطف وكانك تداعبها هكذا
انها تتحرك بسهوله نعم تتحرك بسهوله نلمس
الجانب الطفولي في هذه الورشه نمزج
الالوان فتبدا في ظهور عندما نضع الماء
بها
الاصباغ الذهبيه لكولورادو الجنوب الفرنسي
تحكي قصه عمرها 230 مليون سنه تراث
جيولوجي لامع وابداع انساني حقق ولا زال
يفعل متعه لا تضاعها للناظرين والزائرين
[موسيقى]